alright folks here it is we've bought 50
loot boxes and earned one as icing on
the cake if you want to cancel your
search for the game Danny will really
get into the loot box opening here the
first one yeah first one's looking nice
and blue come on baby
yeah can you detect but did they move it
back to detect being able all yeah but I
mean make the vermouth what does that
remove but it doesn't look like a vodka
bottle that's all it's yeah it's just a
player icon I don't know there's who's
player icon is that this yeah
soldier alright we're not previewing
each a novel thing we got we got a lot
to get through but I got some good
sprays we'll have to get into your spray
game here later
yeah I'll probably have a better one
later hopefully here's hoping
alright let's go box number three more
blue she's really come on give yourself
a beard at least just your player icon
is generic overwatch I go on here we go
what's next
Fox 4 alright how many boxes is gonna
take for us to get something other than
a blue it's been four and OH
sprays OH throws okay now we're feeling
a little better stuff a little
Widowmaker Rose skin different I mean
I've already got the really cool when
you get with the collector's edition the
better one oh look I got some currency
I'm up to 50 and pay you back here we go
what are we number 6
ooh soldier in the white jacket now does
this make you more visible I don't think
so there are some skins you kind of feel
like that's that's making a bigger
target of yourself like both these skin
sprays sprays that was pretty yeah yep
cute before in that box
love it all right next one I'll give me
some yellows to him blue who's next
got a currency icon oh here we go baby
you got a power got a bunch of currency
and good-looking symmetric skin not the
best symmetric skin well that's all
right
not the best but man's symmetric is the
best I love so much here Louie back on
them blues Oh Winston what do you fancy
here Danny take your pick I mean I
thought probably banana man it is it is
on theme it is a little bit more peanut
butter Winston that's pretty good
all right we'll go for that one look at
this casual May just chilling just
casual reading her readouts oh well
that's perfect for you welcome to the
gun show well we got here oh yes sir get
it that zenyatta
like it free twins it's so good oh my
god only took ten boxes but we got a
goodie
oh the glowing the flames the like giant
feather on top that's great wonderful
that's good I'm gonna use this one -
that's a good all right creepy because
she has no eyes Fox 11
nope wait a Miss oh my got a duplicate
so they got Phi is five or they give you
welcome to the gun show
next up blues blues blues more gold yeah
yeah you do you do play fair enough that
you should get a different spray yeah I
gotta say the first after you know
getting a bunch of sprays in beta having
a generic spray just depresses me now
what's this OH highlight intro alright
you gotta do it though yeah that's
pretty good victory pose casual I
couldn't even tell if that was the
non-generic I think what's the generic
when he crosses his oh yeah purple pants
sure what's this that's a spray or
Bjorn's like IKEA schematic that's great
yo you take your hammer you take five
scrap or you know five hits another perp
that's a skin right oh yeah it's like a
little bit of softer color desert little
more gray thank you that's a cool one I
love these things
what are those things save a massive one
of these in the blizzard office when I
was there two months ago I feel like
pretty fun I want if they have a massive
one of those I want it to be squishy so
you can like jump on it yeah it is the
one they had was hey when the purple
ends up being gold don't do that -
you're not gonna hate it when you can
buy a sweet skin at the end of this
opening situation folks if you're just
joining us we are in the middle of
opening 51 loop boxes back to back to
back to back to back and so far got some
gut I think the highlight so far has
maybe from even that Zenyatta skin yeah
we got the efreet skin just a moment ago
and a ton of sprays we're not really
delving in the spray situation right now
how many we got a running total on all
the skins we got so far probably like
like seven or eight you know we can no I
have not been keeping track alright well
put something right hand in paper here
but like yeah we're tally it up I got
some so looked at almost 500 go as well
of course this did cost $40 justice
we've we have 33 to go oh my god so I've
already spent like lunch for the rest of
the week I guess mm-hmm how worth it
will it be just hanging that he had the
his brass knuckles say left on his left
hand
oh yeah just so you can keep track
maybe that sounded oh it is a green
merci I like that one equip all right
not a box we have yet to get the gold
legendary
we've had some purples yes that's true
but no gold yet and we are about 20
boxes deep whoa okay to see some
duplicates sprays another purple I'm not
even halfway here oh we got a little
McCree damn highlight intro it's a
badass mother effer
so for when yes it is nice it is indeed
I like it uzuki
I like the bean I love it my favorite
thing about this is that I'm going to be
like a level 4 player with all these
skills so many everyone's gonna know yep
everyone's gonna know what I did a dirty
thing I did so you know what's happened
I just tell you what top the intro
there's this horrible thing has happened
Chris where I'm unlocking all these
boxes but what's actually happened is
that now the feeling of opening a new
crate means nothing to me oh he's dead
it's like he's gonna have to get another
40 like next week rice like it like I
feel like when I earned one of these
it's gonna be like oh whatever
yeah it'll take a while for this the
thrill to wear off you are binging
that's a pretty cool that's cool
that's cooler than the white and it's
got this tough this teeth on the mouth
oh yeah the skull that's good good
purple skins where is that gold it's
gonna come from
feel like I've gotten this one 12 times
like I get it I wonder if it's gone up
the duplicate like now it's plus 15 year
like if because you've gotten it so many
times it like that's a clue comes more
valuable we've reached over the halfway
point Chris we're over at the halfway
point they're still chugging along we've
got a decent amount of purples but no
gold yet let's hope that the second half
is a bit better than the person a little
more productive yeah
more blue ease steady stream of Blues
big tracer poster up to 704 didn't go I
think by the time we're done with this
you'll have at least a grant to buy that
whatever Elite skin you want
oh you mean Winston yeah oh you mean
safari Winston absolutely 100% Safari
Winston every time you're not going for
pervs Aria we'll get a better Zarya
maybe that's that looks awful that looks
like somebody made this in Adobe
fireworks
Macromedia oh that's a cool one little
green lemon-lime diva I mean every diva
is cool because they're so big yep
unlike so the color change is like it
has a bigger impact of the cooling yeah
oh here we go
I'm around the PERT pipe Oh money money
money money looks like a beetle yeah it
does like a diva does have those like
insect skins to do the gold what's it
gonna be Oh a little duplicate skin I'm
gonna row look at the gold one soldier
76 night ops his face you can see they
have the eye thing his eyes have other
things his hair is slightly receding dog
tags are jangling know that we're up to
905 in doe as well almost almost worth
the investment to almost look at it
doesn't this is another like macromedia
fireworks skin alright so right here we
are we are currently I think at two
golds as the chat pointed up as anyatta
skin was gold okay that was not a
so oh I do like the I do like the junk
ready look I could just get the
overwatch logo basic logo not basic
enough for you now add the words to
literally tell people what you're
spraying man this is cool I like jail
bird you know bird looks like the Joker
a bit or something in this one mm-hmm
that's a pretty cool man one two
who I don't I don't know about it then
II don't know it looks like a fat baby
road hog but it's also supposed to be a
pig ooh dude look at again to pee Dukes
didn't realize books can you apply book
spray to everyone and just become like a
warrior for literacy
it's just Winston yeah every time you
kill someone just put a reading stamp on
them we got 15 of our 51 boxes this one
again how many times I gotta be for the
horn all right it looks like it's not
increasing 55 credits every time you're
getting a duplicate I think a lot of
duplicates I'll just say that getting a
lot of duplicates right now ooh I like
that victory pose
yeah that fusion gun thing plasma there
we go 50 so we're actually over we went
over already
excellent so we combine the money we can
consider the purchase a little later on
yeah dream Oh another gold whoa much
gold Wow whole hunk exchange five hundo
yeah we might have a sec we might have
enough for a second I get to two elites
sure let's use that which meanwhile I
use with bastion today we really want to
get into my beeps she has a heart emote
that like draws a pixelated heart on the
screen oh yeah and then it didn't it
evaporates it's really good I paid for
that 100 oh my god this is some
straight-up storm with the Lion Heart
oh that's good that is so awesome
chuckles it's nothing he's got the claws
Matt it looks like he stepped out of
Stormwind and you can see his sad old
man face yeah
scarred dirty eye nice work equip
equipped yep I'll be keeping that one
that's cool
hey what up victory pose sure confident
confident I would describe Lucio as
confident yes oh my god Roni what is it
220 shy of a second one come on toughie
wants a brand new skin you got one I
mean I mean did you see the last one
right now his wish
sorry dude you want to go back to like
the old Navy version but it can't see
his face once you see his face like mud
oh I guess his pants are dirty sure
dirty sure whatever spray I like that
one mercy it's pretty good just put that
over anyone elses spread you ever see oh
we've only got eight of these left
oh our loot box marathon is coming to a
close the end is in sight
Dani oh does not care about Zarya skins
in the least hope you can tell my plays
are yeah oh here we go here we go purple
purple oh that's not some straight
matrix is whelming that's that's is that
best piano Reeves impression yeah right
there positively well nope you want to
rock your widow swing it oh so many
Grey's so many sprays somebody tubes
well we might not do it we need 165
you're gonna do it four boxes left folks
to get to the 2k
three left oh I just got a hundred it
just popped up I got a hundred telling
you we're gonna make it
see should she so like 150 so I guess
that the gold counter if you look on the
top right you can see a pop up before
four oh you need 15 more or like one
dupe if I am shy of 50 I'm gonna be so
disappointed so the next box is the last
box that we purchase that we paid for
and then the next one after that is one
that I earned with my own bike back to
level 4 okay cross your fingers we hope
we can we hold hands pushed over to top
all right to grass today go the exchange
rate is $40 to 35 so that's everything
we got out of the 50 Lu crates
let's just open the one I earn yeah see
cuz he knows one was all you Danny it's
got a pop a legend jury is gonna be like
eight sprays yep and that's the metro
line yep precisely there you go whoo so
we came at it out with oh yeah what's
the tally let's go let's just take a
look at the hero gallery real quick all
right or just like go back let's see the
general numbers okay cuz you're pretty
much at zero for most of these pretty
much right I had a couple of sprays and
stuff but that was a bit so Genji and
Roadhog were the big winners in terms of
visit specific items whereas macri's in
the basement before everyone's got new
things but I think our big wins were the
zenyatta and Reinhart skins yes for sure
let's go to gotta so any skin we got for
him yeah it's probably the best skin
they're so good I mean I do also like
the yeah the the Horace head but the
efreet is dope yeah which other ones
were good Reinhart was the Lionheart
skin oh yeah look at that that like blue
glow his other ones are Oh at-at Stone
one
pretty dope actually that the stone is
also take that one over it but uh yeah
sure
solid solid which other ones were good
we got a cynic fair as my go-to for
instance and for her I gosh oh I got the
security chief one I didn't realize well
that's cuz you purchased oh so this is
the only one that I got um which is
pretty good does she I mean she has some
other ones that are pretty cool got some
sprays for her too yep that's pretty
cool
probably go for this one here and then
let's see my other one I play a lot of
is a Widowmaker let's just see her real
quick yeah you got two skins here you
got the rose and the CN oh yeah the Rose
one is Noir is the one that you guess
for the the pre-purchase and for the for
pre-purchasing overwatch so I guess that
was not like well yeah some RI ones I
mean even like I feel like I got a skin
for everyone mmm the Baskins the best
thing though is that we have now 2000
gold to spend on anything we want that's
true so I can get any of these look at
us do you have a skin in mind or do you
want to maybe come back in the stream
later and spend your money all of these
skins this game is I mean the one I
really want every time is Safari Winston
because it's just there to actually
write this yeah go under see under the
other pith helmet I think and the
mustache that's amazing
that's probably the one I like you've
been talking about a lot why not pull
the trigger on it that's incredible that
Native American yeah Pacific Northwest
look I think I need to go for the ones I
play the most yes so I don't get the
most out of it for gonna buy this yeah
do it i buy this look at that I mean I
didn't even get a skin for her anyway
you did you got so you got like an
emerald green color yeah great achievers
alright but look at that look at that
yes good and I guess let me put let me
put the Turk on the other one the
Winston Safari you don't want to do it
yet just just let it marinate okay this
is probably the one the black bird can
ask arrayed looking this is like some
Assassin's Creed syndicate nonsense it
definitely is I'm gonna
probably this one I don't even know what
to say about that that's just that's
NSFW right there so feathery thank you
so much for watching if you're watching
this on demand thank you so much
watching the video of us opening all
these things that would cost me $40 do
you decide for yourself whether or not
it was worth it for you